kyogre's families have been enjoying the
spring sunshine after a long winter that
saw momentous political events in this
central asian country
one often described as the most
democratic in the region
but that may be changing dalet
says the new president's plan to change
the constitution
could be a step backwards on the path
towards full democracy
kyrgyz people have a strong will towards
freedom we don't tolerate backward steps
away from democracy
there are more serious issues to be
solved in the country than the
constitutional referendum
such as unemployment but it's better not
to destroy what we have already achieved
so far
this is the day that the new president
sudhar japarov was freed from jail by
supporters during protests
after parliamentary elections were
annulled in october following
widespread allegations of vote buying he
was serving an
11 year prison term for kidnapping at
the time a crime he denies
because he was out of the country when
it happened
in the six months since sarah japaroff
was greeted by supporters on these steps
he has
changed the political landscape in
kyrgyzstan dramatically
even before he won the presidential
election in january he said
that the parliamentary system of
governments in kyrgyzstan had failed
he described the system as being
dysfunctional and corrupt
critics say japan's proposed changes to
the 2010 constitution
show he is trying to impose a more
authoritarian form of rule
one which weakens checks and balances
needed to prevent
abuses of power this uh
proposed text of the constitution is
going to change
the rules of the game at least at the
high level
uh toward serious centralization of
power
uh in the office of the president and to
such an extent
that basically no national level
institution will be able to do anything
without participation or sign off on it
by the president the names on the
plaques
are those killed during two of the three
revolutions kyrgyzstan has had
since independence following the breakup
of the soviet union 30 years ago
the fight for democratic rights is
something kyrgyz people are proud of
young members of the recently
established reform party are campaigning
in
municipal elections which are being held
on the same day as the referendum
the presidential rule implies personal
rule
there there's no room little room for
parties
because the the value of parties is
being
down it's being devalued parties are
being represented as something
western something that is imposed
back at the amusement park people enjoy
the warm weather
and rides there's no sign of the
political upheaval of recent months
or the new president's plans for
constitutional change
that many say would put the brakes on
decades
of democratic gains charles stratford al
jazeera
bishkek